when I first learned get one of the most
confusing topics to me was merge
conflicts it seems like I always found
myself in a merge conflict I didn't know
why and I didn't know how to get out of
it but really they're not that
complicated a merge conflict occurs when
there's been a change in the same file
in the same line on the two branches
you're trying to merge together so here
for example if we're working in
index.html on two branches and there
have been changes in line for in both
files that will generate a merge
conflict now for example this is just
one conflict there could be multiple
files or even multiple portions of the
same file with conflicts but for now
let's keep it simple
soget tells you there's a conflict what
do you do next my favorite next step is
to run git status it's an easy way to
clear my head and see exactly which
files have the conflicts in them once I
know what file to look at I open it up
in my favorite text editor and I look
for these merge conflict markers once
you find the merge conflict markers all
you need to do is pick the version of
code that you'd like to keep and get rid
of the merge conflict markers one
version will be above equal signs and
the other will be below you can pick one
delete them both or create something
totally new
it doesn't care just make sure the code
looks the way you want it to and get rid
of the merge conflict markers save those
changes and commit them and get will
know the merge conflict has resolved